>> Sean: CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRA OCASIO-CORTEZ NOW
ACCUSING KELLYANNE CONWAY OF
QUESTIONING HER FACE FOLLOWING
US TWITTER EXCHANGE IN THE
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
SRI LANKA ATTACK.
YOU ADMIT YOU ARE NEVER SHY
ABOUT RESPONDING, WHICH I LIKE,
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, I DID THE SAME
THING A LOT.
MAYBE MORE THAN I SHOULD HAVE,
EVEN.
>> WELL, SEAN, I USUALLY LEAVE
HER ALONE.
I'M NOT AS PROLIFIC A TWEETER AS
SHE IS AND SOME OTHER PEOPLE.
THEY BELIEVE SHE AND SOME OF
THESE OTHER FRESHMEN LIKE ILHAN
OMAR, TO LEAVE ALONE BECAUSE
BASICALLY WHEN THEY SPEAK, IT'S
A GIFT.
IT TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, WHEN
SHE HOLDS FORTH ABOUT WE CAN'T
HAVE ANY MORE GAS, ANY MORE
COWS, ANY MORE GAS COMING FROM
COWS.
SHE SAYS THAT WORLD IS GOING TO
END IN THE NEXT 12 YEARS.
DOESN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND THE
WAY TAX INCENTIVES WORK.
SHE GOT RID OF AMAZON AND THE
25,000 JOBS IT WAS GOING TO
BRING TO NEW YORK AND THEN SAID
WE CAN'T GIVE AWAY $3 BILLION TO
THEM.
MEANING SHE REALLY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE WAY THAT THE TAX
INCENTIVES WORK.
IT IS SO LOW BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO
JOBS.
IT IS SO CRAZY.
HEY, THIS GLASS OF WATER CAN WIN
IN THE DEMOCRATIC DISTRICTS.
THEY ARE JUST FIVE OF THEM?
REALLY RUSHING BACK SOME OF
THESE PROGRESSION FRESHMEN
BECAUSE SHE IS UNDER ENORMOUS
PRESSURE.
TO TRY TO GET THINGS DONE.
BUT I REALLY HAD TO CALL HER OUT
HERE BECAUSE I AM ON TELEVISION
SHOWS, AND I'M OUT CONSTANTLY.
WHY DIDN'T DONALD TRUMP SAY
THIS, WHY DID HE USE THAT WORD?
DOES ANYBODY ASK ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, WHO GETS A HERO'S
WELCOME, DID ANY OF YOU BOTHER
TO ASK HER WHY SHE HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY SILENT ON THE
MASSACRE AGAINST SRI LANKA ON
EASTER SUNDAY?
AND I ONLY ASKED THAT BECAUSE I
NOTICED THAT SHE HAD TWEETED
MANY TIMES ABOUT THE KILLINGS IN
THE MOSQUE IN NEW ZEALAND.
SHE TWEETED ABOUT OTHER THINGS,
AND I WAS ON THE SAME SHOW,
CONDEMNING VIOLENCE AGAINST
PEOPLE OF ALL FAITHS.
I SAID SPECIFICALLY BY AN AMAZON
MOSQUE IN NEW ZEALAND, THE
CHRISTIANS IN TAXES, THE TREE OF
LIFE SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH,
THE SYNAGOGUE IN CALIFORNIA, AND
ON AND ON IT WENT.
SO MY BOSS, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IN MAY, AND
OTHERS, WE ARE CONDEMNING
ATTACKS ON PEOPLE OF ALL FAITHS.
PEOPLE SHOULD FEEL SAFE AT ALL
TIMES, PARTICULARLY IN A HOUSE
OF WORSHIP.
WHY IS SHE SILENT?
SHE SAID ON TWITTER, AND I SET
IT ON A TV SHOW.
HEY, I WAS AWAY FROM TEXT.
I WAS VISITING MY GRANDMA FOR
EASTER.
THE VERY NEXT DAY, STILL PICKING
THROUGH THE RUBBLE IN SRI LANKA,
LOOKING FOR SURVIVORS OR OF THE
DECEASED.
SHE HAD TIME TO TWEET ABOUT A
NETFLIX DOCUMENTARY ABOUT HER.
SO I THINK THAT WE ALL CHOOSE
WHAT WE WAY AND ON.
PEOPLE ARE NOT COMPELLED TO
WEIGH IN ON EVERYTHING.
>> Sean: NO, I THINK YOU DID
THE RIGHT THING.
>> I THINK IT WAS -- IT'S NOT
ABOUT HER FAITH.
IT'S ABOUT HER SELECTIVITY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, LUCK.
THE FACT IS THERE ARE OVER 100
DEMOCRATS, THESE PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT HER.
GET RID OF COWS AND AIRPLANES
AND THE COMBUSTION ENGINE.
BUT THEY PLAY TO AN INNATE FEAR
OF PEOPLE.
THE THEORY -- WE PROMISE EVERY
WORRY IN YOUR LIFE IS GONE.
AND I'M LIKE REMEMBER KEEP YOUR
PLAN AND PAY LESS?
THEY NEVER FULFILLED THAT
PROMISE.
THAT'S THE SCARY PART.
>> I THINK YOU'D LIKE TO SMART
FOR THAT.
SPEAKING OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
SHE GOT A LOT OF FANFARE, HERE
IS WELCOME FOR THAT, THEN WHEN
IT WENT TO THE ACTUAL VOTE, NOT
A SINGLE DEMOCRAT VOTED FOR IT.
THEY WERE SO COWARDLY, THEY
VOTED PRESENT.
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT SAID WE MUST HAVE
IT.
THIS IS THE FUTURE.
THEN THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE GUTS
TO EVEN GET AN AFFIRMATIVE VOTE.
SO A LOT OF THESE IDEAS SOUND
GREAT.
THEY ARE A SUGAR HIGH, EMPTY
CALORIES.
AMERICANS ARE TOO SMART FOR
THAT.
YOU HEAR FREE HOUSING, FREE
HEALTH CARE.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
BE THE ONES PAYING THE BILLS.